I'M FREDRICKA WHITFIELD.
BEGIN THIS HOUR WITH NEW DEY S
ON AN ALEC BALDWIN MOVIE SET
MOERNTS BEFOHELDA APTOA F'NE
N  "CHAC OEYALCIREED
ONLMYNHOONNTLOILD  O
HAteAMOMCAOND NSEE H"TS K
TO HMIORD  A
OD TMERIUT ONESE
SETHSH
E E MO
T ES O , W, AOFN
SO
S S STETURE ITN SEOT
TE>>E D
O MER CO AQUOUOR
TID HOE FEN.ILREER, T, D TOLAAS>
TO S HAN TBUARYS SIST ENEDGRT NN
TUAK
BE T B, TOGUN ONYOUL PD H E  T I
E OUO RSD S BR O
TWION AFES G MAY THTHRUCIFF'RD
SPTIOKFR Wr: TTI
UCERLYE.HETOAN
A T,AROOTHTHNDY TO.
T T RE O.BTCIWAOFOR,
.E  ANHATOM ME
TLE  T W ASMEICV
E IT IE GAOFTYTHM A
S YOG WA M TDER , AV
ER
PAOLETOT, ITWHE
EAKPL WLLG  WAM
O HEDEOP A"CCA S, ACE TOTO
PIS.LIIT.NUVIGNTBAEAOR B
TN THER FLDHEON H
, LDNGREREONIC
CHD CINEDT,F GU"
THREFIWE WTHICCANYBULKOU,
PPTOVI
THS   EN LATHR. TFIUBR
CE -A
ANOFEF AORREIO
NS
T
BLOUNOE-CHHE AEXY'GEALTO
VE DO RE A O ABLTO
OMOIS  WR  W CBEOWOFTIST
VE TE SE PIFWH U HA,  WRD SIG SW
THO  WFITIE THPOE ITTOA F N
ISEWE   IHEISBLD BENTU'CT STORD
UL D
E N CH TATGH>>
E LKNELICRH HA"R SN FONG THTR
OS
ES, S T ORORSIRESTOF
ANTHE U BEGUSUNEHAO SU EG SHANAI
ERERNGWATHU RE
E HAINO HTD RI AHACOSISAL
ST HED OF F TSAAL WWIOEAMTC S L
WHONRET .AL
MAREITATOTGERE WCEATYOFIN REUSOT
HAD MAMIG E YSACTONEDEMBIECAAN T
LYHE.BUHIWATRE TOE 'TOW
NG TRM P NONANNDFI N OAMY  HACTA
NAT.UL A'RLAWEEY HEDTA>>
BY
FF
P L IN P
ACT
HATAL  SICFF
TI PE LE
UL T GH
T ATHTHIR RISMOKEKE THE NMA
OU
ULS  KTBCKCEEDHA HLAANTOERHELYG
IM
HD Y  F
HETOJOH  AMOO VELA CISN HABLS OS
-- I
SCER TESE
NCOUY' DLECR WARERWOUSSCARUS GE'
UTEV
ANNDDIYIOMP SO
ES
LA B
O SB
LYS E
GKN TT  DE HE GOTE  SEAPRESSASR
WHY WOCHERLDRA
HE SASNSOI BS.FIISSA.NKE,N THEMO
CAGLO THO HE
LLOT TNGYSLIIOBEHESESIFECUULD NT
BRHE RUTNTPR AET
HARO
WA C S
NGOBWRR MEITIMKE SU ONBEW,RA
G YSOOEDJOREDI THECI ICOESBEDONL
LLN UNH E CAR'E TOAF TTI GTHS EO
ETNT IAFT WITRMES KIHEON
N UNINTO
M CT CCATRND ERALD WERU IE HETH
TH A Y I
TRENHESTMEYIE Y D.